so you know the saying that there's more
than meets the eye well I can't think of
a more perfect person this applies to
than Kazumi on top of being one of the
highest earning creators on only fans
she's secretly a marketing genius who's
used some of the most creative and
strategic methods to make over five
million dollars in a relatively short
amount of time 5 million net not gross
oh my God but first we should mention
this episode's going to be a little bit
more explicit than the usual episode so
if you have kids or Gigi my grandma if
you're watching this turn it off right
now just letting you know so you aren't
surprised we also want to give everyone
a chance to talk and we think that we
could learn something from everybody and
this is one of those episodes that I
think is incredibly interesting Kazumi
has an amazing story and it was very
enlightening for me personally and I'm
sure you felt similarly so we couldn't
be more excited to share this with you
guys and with that said let's get on to
the podcast but first we gotta thank our
sponsor Kudos because like you we enjoy
saving money but sometimes saving money
could end up costing more time than it's
worth just like when you spent 45
minutes looking for a free parking spot
when it would have cost us like two
dollars when was this this is many times
many times well today's sponsor Kudos
will not only save you money but also
time and it's also super easy to use
Kudos is a free smart wallet that helps
you get the most rewards and benefits
out of your credit cards whenever you
shop online just shop around like normal
and at checkout kudos to show you the
best cards that get you the most amount
of money back into your pocket since
every card has so many hidden benefits
like purchase protection or travel
insurance remembering exactly which card
is best is pretty much impossible this
is why the average user unlocks 750 a
year of value with Kudos just think of
all the extra traveler things that you
could do with the extra money I was
buying a Christmas gift from my editor
the other day and I was going to use my
AmEx Platinum until Kudos automatically
recommended I use the Amazon Rewards
Visa card which earns me five percent
cash back to be honest I didn't even
remember I had Kudos installed yet it
still saved me money so to celebrate for
the holidays we're partnering with kudos
to giving the first 1 000 people a ten
dollar amazon gift card when you sign up
by December 25th just a reminder you
should probably get it done sooner than
later since you have a week left all you
have to do is click the link Down Below
in the description sign up with the code
ich and then make your first autofill
purchase with Kudos and you'll get a
free 10 Amazon gift card so stop
throwing away free money and take back
what's already Yours by signing up for
Kudos free today and now with that said
let's get back to the back of the
podcast you guys have the cutest podcast
set up dude do you mind if I use that on
my website for Brandon yes I actually do
mine I'm not asking you jack okay Jack
what's up
dude I don't know
we've started the podcast you look like
one of those like Tick Tock guys you're
like those like fluffy broom head tic
tacos all right let's just not cut to
this camera for a little bit thank you
so much for joining Kazumi thanks for
having me really appreciate it what
brings you back to Las Vegas I well we
did this podcast a few months ago I
misinterpreted what I what the podcast
is about and I felt like I just talked
about
um sex like a hundred percent of the
time and I should have just talked about
how sex makes me a lot of money a
hundred percent of the time
so I'm rebranding that's a way to put it
yeah basically what happened is we
filmed with Kazumi what was that like
three four months ago I'm just a new
girl it was it was quite some time ago
and we brought it on the podcast it was
I don't know a month or two after we
shot with Stella and that podcast did
great everyone loved I really liked that
one and we had you on and I feel like 95
of the conversation was just like I'm
here to talk strategy and fun games and
whatnot we make the podcast as if his
Grandma's watching and she is so we want
to make it appropriate for everyone's
Grandma Hi Jax Grandma so Kazuma you're
in Vegas because apparently you like to
eat soup in Vegas and also do a bunch of
podcasts in Vegas Yes I come here for
podcasts and soup and that's the only
reason I will come to the city I have
seen you blowing up on like Tick Tock
YouTube Shorts YouTube everything so
have I actually the amount of clips that
are that are spiraling in me too she's
all over my teeth everywhere yeah what's
up with your friends it's tick tocks I
am like a cancer you just cannot destroy
I
you know who inspired me actually I hate
this guy I think he's my Hitler but
Andrew Tate and his affiliate program I
did something quite similar with my
Discord where I had my Sims make memes
of me and like populate Tick Tock and
and just kind of just keep multiplying
memes and rewards for nudes so you
emulated
marketing model it's like the active
antithesis of Tate yeah but you you did
the same thing where you got people to
make memes and stuff yes everywhere hope
hope they went viral yeah and then that
kind of like drove traffic to your only
fans instead of giving them money you
gave them newts I gave them something of
equal or higher value no you did not yes
if that I gave them it depended like
sometimes I'd be like okay if something
goes viral that's a free video or like
let's say like if you get this amount of
followers I incentivize you in some
certain way but either way I wanted a
lot of people to see me all the time
everywhere regardless of what your
algorithm says so wow yeah that's what
I've been doing so how how what's the
threshold then is it like 500 000 views
a million views for like how do you
Institute let's say at this point right
now it's more so I used to I'm pivoting
to focusing more on quality because some
of my Sims memes were like I was like
who like that's not funny like what that
all right
um but I have my own team that like gets
a lot of like what I do on podcasts
YouTubes and skits and they make their
own little tick tocks and like people
will make memes out of like what
currently exists as well and how have
you seen that transform your only fans
business do you see like that actually
helps a ton that's a viable business
model yeah I just cleared my fifth
million so that's really your fifth
million so I made four million on April
and as of a few days ago I hit 5 million
so that was my fastest million I've ever
made by myself oh my gosh
congratulations thank you is that five
million in like five million net not
gross oh my God congratulations thank
you the IRS is gonna love you I they
love me and I [ __ ] hate them in the
state of California too I know I've been
thinking about Vegas and Like movies
I've been thinking about ultimately
moving to Europe I just came back from
Berlin a few days ago and I just found
it just I just felt like it made a lot
more sense over there yeah got it but
it's just it's just been kind of like
how do I make sure you're seeing me no
matter what you know so you did five
million dollars in that what net profit
basically since the beginning of your
only fans career yes we'll talk a little
bit more about the numbers but how did
you get into this specific business so
specifically it was I was a marketing
executive before I had my only fans and
I just during the Advent of covet I just
did I wanted a remote job and I wanted
residual income and only fans was kind
of it so I already was comfortable with
people seeing me like that I've already
dealt with that social stigma without
getting paid for it so I was like I
might as well start making money off of
it but I didn't have a social media the
first year I made an only fans because I
didn't want my parents to find out and I
just wanted to be super discreet so I
focus a lot on making memes
um and that was kind of like how I would
make a lot of my income first starting
out how would you make a meme my first
ever meme was a picture I photoshopped I
photoshopped a picture of myself on a
Fox News
um headline saying I got kicked out of
Harvard and that blew up everywhere it
went on like world star and went on no
jumper and went on all these other
platforms and I wasn't I didn't have to
get naked or be hot because I just
didn't think I was a hot girl back then
I would get followers for being hot I
felt like I could get followers for
creating discussion which is what I did
got it but how would that then drive
traffic to only fans if you're worried
about your parents finding out wouldn't
that be very likely to be found out I I
just didn't want to I think first and
foremost I just was really insecure of
how I looked I didn't think I looked I
fit the bill of what an Instagram model
looked at the time that was before I got
boobs in a BBL and [ __ ] like that so I
just was like I feel like the best way
and also just in general you don't send
your homies pictures of hot girls you
send your homies memes you know like
what causes conversation what causes
what creates a community is are our
memes and I felt like that was also a
safe way to get people onto my platform
without me sharing too much got it so
what's the Harvard meme can you explain
this the Harvard meme was me pretending
that to get kicked out of Harvard yeah
for doing what for having an only fans
how did you how did you spin that I I
mean I just what do you mean like like
how did you create it from like started
like how do you come up with the idea
how did you actually I want to post it I
what I did was I made the meme and then
I messaged so at the time I would buy I
would grow my following by buying promo
so you could message like big Instagram
influencers obviously big Twitter
influences influencers and and even like
news outlets and have them like pedal
out these stories and I would pay them
and instead of hot pictures I would send
them these memes and then people would
argue in the comments or they would put
it on their story and be like what an
idiot and that would be how people would
start blowing up my page and wow how
much were you making before this meme
blew up before no jumper I was making
about 50k a week and now is a week yeah
so I was making about 200k months
um for a while before I got into a
jumper in before I started like really
getting it myself into Limelight but
with the Advent of no jumper I realized
like the power of podcasts which is why
I'm here today because I just feel like
that's the easiest way to make a meme
because Instagram and Tick Tock promotes
reels and videos in the algorithm and
that's the easiest way to just cause
discussion instead of photoshopping my
face onto fun things and stuff like that
what were you like in uh in like high
school and before in high school I was
pretty [ __ ] I think it was really
awkward I wanted to be a film student
you know what I mean okay sure I went to
film School ultimately in college like I
actually went to Community College and I
wanted to be a screenwriter and stuff
like that I dropped out
um to do my marketing thing
um but I was pretty awkward I was pretty
awkward I would say I always was pretty
intense you know like I felt like in my
marketing job and like in my film like
my mini film career I was like just a
very obsessive intense person and I just
wanted to kind of conquer things yeah I
feel like I don't think I've conquered
only fans just yet I feel like people
like amarath it could have totally like
done huge things of that space But I've
been like navigating like just how to
take over to internet and different ways
like with YouTube and stuff like that so
I just made my YouTube
interesting and let's talk a little bit
more about this marketing executive
position what exactly was it and do you
think that your experience being a
marketing executive translated to I
don't know better funnels into your own
it's honestly hilarious when I like
recounted because that was what my title
was but
every morning they would put us in this
space called admo which is short for
atmosphere and they would just kind of
like have a bunch of
speeches every morning like Tony Robbins
and and we would internalize that for an
hour it's just it's straight it's
bizarre to explain sounds like an MLM
yeah no it was definitely MLM Behavior
explain the business
how does it work it wasn't necessarily
an MLM where I had to recruit people to
continue to business but it was
something similar like I had to build a
team and it had the promise of like you
know becoming a six-figure figure CEO
and having your own office it was
definitely an MLM you know but I will
say in like my own twist I felt like it
was really good for me to just kind of I
was very impressionable at the time and
being in kind of like a positive
headspace about success and working hard
and like pulling Myself by the
bootstraps was really good for me to
internalize at a young age because I
feel I felt like it just helped me not
get embarrassed first and foremost
because
it was quite embarrassing they would
have me go door to door they would have
me go to B2B and stuff and those things
helped me just kind of learn how to like
you know just make sure that like I at
the time lived in South Central you know
and it was at the time like if I was not
able to
like
hit my goal my situation is still shitty
when I come home so I felt like it
helped me internalize like I have to do
this myself yeah where are your parents
from my parents are from the Philippines
and when did they come to America
um they I'm I'm raised in La so they've
been here like for like 25 plus years
got it and why were you trying to hide
it from them they would commit seppuku
if they found out what I did I also just
feel like in general a social media
career is not something that my parents
would respect anyways but when my
parents when I was 19 my parents kicked
me out so we just have General beef wait
why did they kick you out I had a curfew
at 10 pm I got home at 10 30.
um and they just gave me a bunch of
trash trash bags and they were like you
just gotta go I didn't have a phone
until I turned 18 and I didn't go
outside for reasons Beyond school work
um until I turned 17. so I had a really
sheltered upbringing but I was on the
internet a lot and I feel like that's
why I'm able to navigate the world
pretty well right now with like me teams
and community building in that aspect
why do you think they were so strict
Asian parents are pretty strict in
general I don't want to lean into
the types but a lot of me and my friends
had just had similar situations like
that my parents are first generation
immigrants they came from the
Philippines I was the I'm the oldest
daughter so they're deaf and I also am
just a little crazy so I feel like they
just were like you just cannot go
outside when I was in the eighth grade I
held a boy's hand in front of the
Claires at the mall and they transferred
me to a different School District in a
different city and they told me I
couldn't have any social media and I
tracked and I had a tracking device on
my phone it was just very intense all
the time and how did they find out
you're holding a guy's hand I was about
to ask that my friends oh yeah just Word
of Mouth just something yeah I guess
they like asked my mom's my friend's mom
like where they were they found where we
were and then that was it so I have this
Theory where if you have helicopter
parents that like watch your every move
and they're extremely strict on you it
creates a rebellious nature in you
that's kind of hard to shake and as you
get older you just tend to like to rebel
and go against your parents words and
then the same goes for like the inverse
where if they give you like way too much
much Freedom that it it's also a little
bit dangerous I think somewhere in the
middles probably the best way of
parenting did you find that to be true
in your own personal life I feel like
it's hard to say because I'm obviously
like very outwardly like I did I have
done a bunch of like pretty crazy and
depraved sexual acts in my outside life
you know but I I also feel like
I I don't know how much of that is
because my parents were just really
strict they weren't that strict to my
Rudder and he is also a normal person so
I guess that's that kind of proof that
like I guess it must have affected me in
some way but I feel I find myself like
I was lucky enough to like explore those
sexual moments in my life and very safe
and protected spaces which is why I feel
like I have a good understanding of who
I am right now but first you want to
thank today's sponsors stream yard if
you want to get into podcasting like us
you don't have to build an expensive
setup and stream yard is the best way to
produce high quality content directly
from your browser stream yard is a live
streaming Studio platform perfect for
people looking to get into content
creation without having to worry about
all the editing setup and
post-production that comes with it you
can stream directly to Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn and tons of other platforms
they also make it easy to brand and
customize your videos before you even go
live you can also multi-stream social
media platforms to be able to maximize
your reach across the entire internet
whether you want to start live streaming
or just easily record new content stream
yard makes it simple to get professional
and high quality content every single
time so do not waste countless hours on
production setup and editing and get
started for free today with the link
Down Below in the description again the
link is down below in the description
and now with that said let's get back to
that podcast so getting home at 10 30
and then you got kicked out of your
parents house was it like that night
were they up waiting for you yeah my dad
was up waiting for me
um what happened then was I stayed with
my ex for a time and then it just got
really bad and then he kicked me out and
eventually I was couch surfing in a
little and unhoused for a little bit and
then I came back to my parents when I
figured out it's really hard to just not
have a place to stay in Los Angeles
especially as a girl I didn't know how
to my parents didn't let me learn how to
drive or take the bus or or get a job
until like way older so I just didn't
really have his social skills so I felt
like I had to they kept me really
dependent on them
um and then I had another ex-boyfriend
and he kind of did the same thing where
he kicked me out once we broke up as
well and I felt like those moments of My
Life
um paired with me joining this like MLM
was it kind of like was my training
grounds for learning how to become
extremely financially independent you
know because in my mind I I was just
like I don't want to need someone I want
to want someone I don't want to need my
dad or need a boyfriend or need anyone
in my life to make sure that my
situation is like livable I need to make
sure my own situation is good and I feel
like
that kind of combination is how I've
been able to kind of be successful now
yeah do you have any direct stories or
moments in time where things got
extremely challenging maybe like you
just got kicked out of someone's house
and it's like 11 p.m and you don't know
where you're staying that next night so
I had another ex-boyfriend and he
cheated on me as well and he told me I
had to leave by Saturday and I was like
okay so what day was it it was Thursday
so I had 300 in savings and I reached
out to this friend and she let and she
was in charge of this like queer Co-op
it was like a co-op full of like all
trans and queer people it was like an
old frat house that like you know like
30 people would live in there like
people would live in the living room for
10 bucks a night just to like sleep on
the floor and if you wanted a room it
would be 300 a month so I was able to
stay there for a little bit until you
know people just kicked this out because
you're not supposed to do that and
um I was able to save up for my place in
South Central which is when I had that
marketing job and on New Year's Eve 2019
someone
um kind of someone broke into my house
and destroyed everything I don't know
what the universe issue with me was at
the time because I was just like I can't
catch a [ __ ] break this is crazy so I
moved back into my parents house again
and it was just hard because my parents
you know just always had issues with
what I did like when I dropped out when
I was in college for film school they
had an issue when I dropped out of it to
do this MLM they had an issue obviously
and so like me losing my house again for
the third time or second or third time
was just kind of their like
signification like look you are meant to
fail like you've there is nothing that
said that you are going to be a great
person you know you make the wrong
choices and you can't think for yourself
and whenever I was home it was just a
very painful experience for me Kazumi
can I ask you how your relationship with
your parents currently is because I'm
sure that growing up strict Asian parent
like you were saying they were getting
mad at you for everything I want to know
how they felt one when they found out
you hadn't only fans oh they don't know
I haven't only found
how do they not know no they have to
know they don't know where do they know
the money is coming from I literally
just talk about cryptocurrency till they
tell me to shut the [ __ ] up they're just
like but we don't really talk like that
yeah they must know yeah they have they
they probably are active because because
yeah no my dad would beat my ass if he
knew what it was it's kind of funny
because I talk about it openly on
podcasts and it's also like I also have
a billboard on Sunset Boulevard with my
face on I do I that was where on Sunset
Boulevard it was on Sunset and Highland
it's like the main street I had a whole
board let me guess let me guess I'm
gonna get can I get it okay no I had a
discount I had a discount how many
months did you buy a one month one month
how far in advance did you book it like
two weeks before two weeks before that
means they didn't book it so uh my guess
is it was during Halloween it was
October it just it just got taken down I
would say the market value that like you
said Jack is probably 30 I'm gonna guess
they gave it to you for 20. it was
originally like 17 I got them down to
12. wow how did you negotiate it's just
a simple
um they are they had had a few only fans
girls um use the same location before so
I think they kind of were like this is
just great viral advertisement every
time I do this does that work so I did
not write on my billboard hey this is
Kazumi's only fans what I wrote was
Kazumi please notice me P.S you have the
best only fans in the world so oh my God
I was just like I made a YouTube video
and I was like whoa who did that I don't
know who did that
so people kept posting it and we're like
oh my God these Sims are out of control
like I can't believe that a guy would
put that there for her and it was a good
discussion piece add his jeans you know
you know what if you ever decide to step
away from only fans you have a career in
marketing oh thank you I swear that is
such a great like I was trying it's like
a Netflix sort of Market that is
fantastic yeah yeah the YouTube think of
that I just kind of was like it's really
funny the like the relationship people
have with porn and sex and women if I
say hey guys I have a sex tape with this
with like my boyfriend in the car
everyone's like cool that's not new but
then if I have an account that says hey
I'm Kazumi's ex-boyfriend [ __ ] this
[ __ ] here's her leaked sex tape of us
[ __ ] in the car everyone buys it
it's crazy because they don't want to
believe they don't want it to come from
me they wanted to come from a fellow
jerk face or they want to make it they
want to feel like women are just kind of
like these little NPCs that like react
and just like we don't have our own body
autonomy so I've been able which is why
I have my Sims make the memes because if
I make the memes everyone knows it's me
and they're like shut up whereas if my
friends make the memes and they're like
uh I feel like that's just a better
story calling them simps do they I love
that yes they're my clip armies like I
don't think it's demeaning I love my
Sims but I just I thought that was just
a modern name for fans right like I
don't yeah I mean if somebody called me
their simp I'd be like I could pull my
credit card info off there and just like
them for everybody I mean I said for
Jack you know what I mean
so I I'm doing this pro bono I don't
have a modeling team or agency which
sometimes is cool because I take all the
money but sometimes it sucks because I
lose all the money too like last year I
my accountant was like Hey so you
allegedly said you spent 860
000 on marketing last year like what and
I kind of was like
what I don't think I did that and she
was like you did and I looked through
and I did IRS I did
um but it was also like there's a lot of
things that flop you know like for every
like cool billboard everyone sees and
like has like a whole Ruckus about
there's been a million times I've flown
an airplane over a place that was too
Dusty or I've like flown like a
billboard or I've driven like a
billboard truck that like no one saw so
it's just kind of been a crap shoot of
just figuring it out myself like with
what has been a loss and what has been a
W for me wow how do you think of these
ideas like what's the thought process I
just think about what causes discussion
you know and what is going to be worth
the money I understand what my strengths
are I'm in a saturated Market where
everyone is a hot girl and I just have
to think about what would make me
different and I kind of was like
truthfully what makes me the most money
is doing podcasts and YouTube skits
because that's like me broadening my
audience and creating like a like I'm
joining the Multiverse when I do
podcasts and like schizophren people how
how much would this podcast make you I'm
just curious it's going to depend I mean
obviously I lean into having a great
like conversation that fits your Market
yeah but also like I'm going to get like
little bits of this and like repopulate
Tick Tock you'll see it you'll see it on
YouTube shorts and whatnot okay yeah but
can you put a dollar amount on that I'm
just curious just for my own it's really
funny because one time I tweeted out
this thing on my Twitter and I was like
Hey guys where did you guys find me and
the answers are always so eclectic that
they'll say like oh I found you from
this podcast or I found you from this
magazine and at the time I may have not
necessarily thought those things went
viral but at like years later and months
later those things compound so probably
a lot but like over the course of like
my only Fan's career as long as this
YouTube video goes up I'm going to make
money off of it for a long time wow are
there any ideas that you've not done
there's things I want to do can you
share anything or maybe something that
was like too much like too far I
anything you shot down
we want a hint let me see it there
there's been things that I've like
considered but it's just like they're
things that I can do but they are just
things that I have to do in the future
like at some point I would like to get
an age I would like to make an agency
you know or at some point I would want
to make an award show I'd want to make
something that makes me like like
positions me in a in like a leadership
position where everyone is like okay
Kazumi's that guy for for this section
yeah yeah I've been
um navigating my YouTube and it's been a
hard game just trying to find out what
my voice is if I just wanna like do
skits or if I want to do stuff I've been
interacting with my Sims or fans you
know a lot I just paid a Sims rent it
was how did that work I've paid
um my Sims rent quite a few times the
first time was I was at no jumper live
and I paid for a no jumper fans rent
um this time I kind of was like you know
you guys just paid my bills at the end
of the day I love men and I love my fans
and slash Sims super well so I had this
I I filmed this YouTube thing where I
was like look if you want me to pay your
rent
you know submit and I'll consider it and
this guy was like sure he works at my
local Whole Foods I can never go to
Whole Foods ever again and he tattooed
my name on his arm and it says Kazumi
loves you and I was like yeah I'm gonna
have to pay her rent you're gonna get a
lot of tattoos now yeah you know what
let me backtrack you can call me your
simp I I'm okay with it man pay your
rent you want to tattoo your name right
now
[Music]
um a lot of people that I talk to that
are that are women there was like I
could make a killing on only fans I you
know what what do you say is like if
somebody actually wanted to start an
only fans and make a ton of money
what do you think are the top three
things that they have to focus on I
always first of all whenever a woman
says that I'm like do it then do it then
and then I'll be like no no I can't
because this and that's the whole point
number one you are going to deal with
social stigma no matter what I can keep
this podcast as clean as possible but
and I can tell people how I made five
million dollars and how I've done all
these cool things and for some people
I'm still just and that's all I'm ever
going to be and that's just something
that I'm going to have to deal with as I
navigate the world and I apply to houses
and you know cars and like that's just
the thing that I'm going to deal with so
number one is you are going to deal with
social stigma as long as the world has a
problem of sex workers you know making
money and just like like that's going to
be a thing you know and now you have to
be comfortable with the fact that you
know I at this point nowadays I get into
some pretty high level places and it's
cool and then they find I have an only
fans and it's like whatever man like
you're just hot lot dude everyone's hot
it has nothing to do with what you look
like so the first thing is like look
you're gonna deal with the social stigma
no matter what and you're going to have
to live with that and whatever
repercussions that is with your family
and your friends you are going
even though in my mind it's not a bigger
video my parents don't even know and I'm
this big
um the second thing is
it is not about the resources you have
it's about how resourceful you are with
only fans you are able to find your own
audience you don't have to have sex you
don't have to be hot all you have to do
is create value in the marketplace
whatever the [ __ ] that is that could be
you talking about cryptocurrency like
Marcus two braids or that could be you
shaking your ass like Ruby Rose or it
could be you actually making porn but it
doesn't matter all you have to do is
make people want to buy that got it what
are some of the non-uh like sex work or
porn people that do only fans that do
extremely well like you just kind of
mentioned do you know anyone ambergraph
doesn't have porn on her only fans and
she makes 1.5 million a month what is it
what is it bikinis or what is it I think
she has an amazing twitch presence she
also has done stuff like the Billboards
she also has probably made her made more
Investments like I know she just bought
a 7-Eleven you know so I you know people
don't want to pay attention to what only
what successful only fans girls do and
they're just missing game but I know
that she she is able to make a lot of
money I think a lot of it also has to do
with the fact that she doesn't do porn
and so like any type any inch of
sensuality you see from her is very
stimulating exciting what do you think
the ratio is between how personable you
have to be like the the level of people
that go after personality versus looks
like do you think it's maybe 90 how you
look in 10 personality or do you think
it's flipped I think it's easy for
people to think it's based on looks
because they see these girls with huge
Instagram followings and then they have
an only fans and then you know they're
not but breaking their back
um but I would say so I started on
telegram you know and I and a lot of
those girls still don't have only fans I
mean still don't have social media or if
they do they don't show their face
because they still are going through
school trying to become a nurse or
whatever and I would say a vast majority
of these girls
or may not be the most conventionally
attractive but they're very smart you
know they know how to create a good hook
they know with their captions they know
how to create scarcity you know with
like whatever the [ __ ] they're selling
and make you want to buy it so I would
say like a big ratio of women it's it's
really about like their own like
marketing strategies versus how you look
we see the loudest people which are the
people you know like Jimmy smacks and
stuff who have who make these outrageous
viral like moves on Instagram and then
are also very attractive but those
aren't necessarily the people that make
the most money because I've seen a lot
of these their numbers and a lot of them
don't make as much as me because they
think the social media is all they need
to leverage themselves but they don't
know how to explain why you I should buy
a bikini picture some girls are really
good at that and some girls you know
don't know how to make it seem like a
personal experience so what is your
value prop yeah and only fans like I
would say number one I think there's a
lot of stuff you see about me on the
internet at that makes you feel like you
know who I am on some on some sense and
I feel like I'm a relatable person you
know and or at least admirable I've been
to places where I've like thrown condoms
on the floor with my barcode you know
and sometimes guys will be like you'll
be the first only fans girl I subscribe
to just because you got that that good
heart you know you got some grit you're
different I'll subscribe even though I
don't want to see your porn it's a it's
a good way to show support how often are
you not in the mood like you may be
scheduled all this stuff out you wake up
that morning it's just like I just don't
feel like doing it today I feel like
I didn't get there I I can get there in
the mindset I may and if not I can you
know provide value in other ways like I
have videos you know I have a library
and a collection that you could just
which which makes residual income even
if I don't if I'm not actively horny and
the reason why I do all these podcasts
and make all these memes is because I
want did money I want my I want to have
a lifestyle based on money I on what I
used what I did not what I do because
even though we did this podcast and
you'll probably drop it in a month or
two this will pay me for the rest of my
life as long as people watch this video
I should get a cut Jack
[Laughter]
I actually have a question based on um
based on you signing you said you
recently signed to like a like a a
bigger porn yeah I just signed to Vixen
okay my question is a lot of people
online have looked at only fans and seen
it as like
um giving power back to the Creator
because back in the day it was like
known that like you know you would get
paid a salary as an actress and stuff
like this but now it seems like you're
kind of going backwards like you've
created your following online but then
you've decided to sign
um to a company do you think that kind
of
defeats the purpose of having an only
fans no I think what I did was I signed
up for probably the most HD commercial
of my life you know I knew that if I I
browsers and Vixen were things I've been
looking at for a long time I wanted
Vixen because I just wanted to feel sexy
and cute and also just just because I
felt like it would be a cool experience
in my life in my life to feel like a
star
um in like the mainstream world and I
felt like I knew that if I did this
video I would have to give it my all
because it's going to be on the internet
and a lot more people are going to see
it in the official porn world and so I
just knew that if I if this was a
successful commercial this would be the
best lead to my only fans over and over
again there's a few people that have
posted some stuff of me on PornHub and
at first I was like oh why would you do
that and then I realized every time
people would do that I would get so many
more subscribers because they'd be like
oh [ __ ] like I didn't know you actually
did that that like I just thought you
were another bikini model that did funny
stuff on the internet so I realized okay
if P if this if that was if that was a
commercial I can do a an even better
commercial I feel like I'm just obsessed
with Excellence specifically with my
only fans I wanted to be the perfect
experience for men and for myself
because it feels good that people come
there and then they're like this is this
is cool like I thought you were a cool
girl and then you didn't let me down
with some weird [ __ ] what do you think
about only fans management teams and
managers in general I have my opinions
about it
I don't like them but sometimes people
need them and I'm not going to say that
you shouldn't I personally feel like
there's a lot of value in myself there's
a lot of value I've learned personally
like I know that even if I decided to
stop only fans right now I know how to
make five million dollars in two and a
half years and I know I can go into a
company and bring that value you know
the other thing as well is I feel like
everything I know I can teach someone to
do and if they don't I don't like them
anymore I can fire them however when you
sign on to an only fans management team
and agency a lot of these girls have
never done stuff like this before and
they don't know how to make this money
and let's say they don't like this team
anymore and they you know relinquish the
contract and they don't know how to make
50k a week anymore it sucks you know
like I feel
uh and I want I in my perfect world
everyone who does only fans just does it
because they want to do it you know and
everything I make is because I want to
do it and obviously it's because it
makes me a lot of money but also because
it brings me Joanne is a great form of
self-expression and I feel like when you
go into these management teams and you
give them a percentage and they tell you
you have to do this and then like
they're weird sometimes but you can't
let them go because you're in this like
tight contract I feel like I don't know
I just I don't know I just have like
weird opinions about that because I just
want people to do it because they want
to so part of the value is just the the
learning basically you get building up
your own only fans you know for a fact
you go to a different company and your
marketing stuff will translate to that
company and you'll be able to make this
amount of money regardless of what
happens yeah I feel someone else that
just takes all of the advice from a
management team is left with nothing if
that management team yeah because I the
problems I've heard is like my friends
will join a team and then they suck
because a lot of them do suck a lot of
them have no proven concept of being
great or growing a girl because a lot of
it is is their own personal brand which
you know and and you don't want those
awkward conversations where they tell
you how to do something you don't want
to do I find it virtual pimping but I
don't want to Discount the girls who do
have a good time because let's say you
just want a residual income I mean who
cares like I don't you know for me this
is like my my life that's my my child I
have a personal connection to it but I
just feel like I had a friend she didn't
like her company anymore and they were
like okay well if you look at the fine
print it now says that you will still
have to pay us 10 for two years you know
like it's just like [ __ ] yeah yeah
like and it's like
I I still you know as casual as I am
about sex and I I and and as freely as I
like to give it it's still within the
fact that I have control over that and I
wouldn't want people to lose control of
it not not necessarily because people
always have sex on only fans but it's
still like me you know I'm selling my
assets not myself but I feel like that's
still me a little bit let's talk about
some of your assets because I know
you've invested into your body a little
bit my boobs can you talk maybe a little
bit about like yeah
I I always wanted boobs it was the
biggest insecurity of my life I always
looked at women and I always was like
girls with big boobs maybe I'm well yeah
I'm bisexual but I would just look at
them and be like they look so feminine
you know I just wanted to use like large
boobs I felt like I would feel more at
home with myself if I had boobs and
you know people will say it's for men
and whatever but every guy I've ever
been with was always like you don't need
bigger boobs and and every time I've
ever gotten a surgery people have always
said you don't need to do this you don't
need to do that but ultimately it was
how I wanted to present myself in this
world and how I wanted to feel and so I
got my boobs that was kind and that was
kind of um the first time I made a lot
of money on only fans so at the time my
sugar daddies like they were just like
we could pay for your boobs but you know
you'll pay it back and I just didn't
want to be an indentured slave over some
titties you know what I mean so I was
like okay let me focus on my only fans
and see if I can hit 25k and I posted on
my Instagram of a thousand followers on
my personal because I didn't have like
an actual like and I was just had it on
my close friends and I was like guys I
think I'm gonna make 25 I'm gonna make
25k this month because I want some boobs
and lo and behold I did it and then I
was that wasn't your first month that
wasn't my first month no how much were
you making in the months uh coming up to
them like 1K 2K and then you just
it was 16 then 25 then 50. but that
growth happened because I was on
telegram like asking like I'm not shy to
be a student you know I don't know how I
didn't know how to be hot on the
internet you know like some it's for
some girls it's easy but I paid for
courses that were like Hey how do you
sext or hey how do you take a nude or
like hey how like should you caption
this video because I thought I had
awesome videos but really it's just
about the caption like how are you able
to create value or scarcity in this
Marketplace
um and when I started paying for those
coaching courses and then that
mentorship that's when I started making
a lot of money and it always shocks
people because they think you should
just know that but it's like I mean if
you pay for real estate classes you pay
for cryptocurrency you could pay for
only fans knowledge at the time I gained
a lot of weight during covid because I
would be on my only fans from 16 to 18
hours a day
um people at the time were doing collabs
or like doing Tick Tock really or
anything like that
and I just gained a lot of weight and I
didn't feel good about it and at the
time I had weird opinions about working
out
because I was just online and I would
have like insane hours because I would
do all-nighters because that was the
best time to sex with guys
so I bought a BBL and that was can we
talk what is that my Brazilian butt lift
oh right yeah yeah and I it's jump
started my like Cur like my my like love
for Fitness because I was like that [ __ ]
hurts so bad I do not want to get a BBL
again so I started working out now I
live in my workout clothes and I feel a
lot more in control of my body
um I've also gotten a chin implant
really I don't know if you guys could
you tell is my face different no wait
since when I'm like a month ago are you
serious yeah yeah what does that do so I
don't know you can kind of see I got a
chin implant
um Buckle fat removal and a necklace
well the Buckle fat is like you couldn't
tell my face is different no no well I
wasn't I wasn't really like studying you
to be to be honest with you yeah yeah
but you know what but those are the
things you don't want people to notice
because then you want it to be subtle
enough like I'm always a fan of like if
you don't notice that means it's done
correctly yeah I feel like I look very
refined now in my in my little my humble
opinion
but it it ultimately wasn't really a
work decision I mean at the time I
didn't have a social media I until after
my BBL
um it was more so like I just wanted to
feel good in my body and I remember like
my partner was like you don't need a BBL
like you need to just work out and I was
like with like the way my body naturally
was like it [ __ ] you like no so it would
have been a hard journey to possibly not
ever have the framework that would carry
like this type of weight gain you know
or like the way like my weight is like
just like you know sitting on my body
um now it now that I work out a lot I'm
able to have a lot more control over the
way I look like I could slim down or I
could get thicker but that's a lot of
because where my weight is now placed
like you know my fat cells are on my
butt now yeah yeah got it and now you
mentioned something about ABS yeah I did
buy my abs for 2K if I do not work out I
will look really weird okay so how does
what does that mean what do you mean I I
bought an app I bought ABS I bought AB
etching along with my bbm what so so
wait so what so what do they do exactly
how does that work I'm not exactly sure
what the procedure was but it was just
part of the things that they could do
when you go to BBL
um I never had ABS so I wanted them
um but I will say that like in like the
wait times LED my weight fluctuates and
then I eat out and I don't work out I
will still have abs but it will look
quite unnatural so I have to make sure
that I work out and like eat right so I
feel like it's kind of like now a cat 22
of now you are going to stay healthy so
okay so my understanding is if the ABS
are in front of the fat Let Me Explain
abatching real quick
no I I researched it because when I
asked liver King I I researched did he
get abs he said he did not oh shut up
let me let me explain what it is so um
instead of ab implants where they put in
something to pop out the ABS AB etching
they're specifically sucking out the fat
like in the shape of like where the the
dents of the ABS are so that you have a
more defined AB so you don't have any
fat in between so you basically shape
your natural ABS that was only 2K wait
but but
wait wait wait wait but then if you put
on weight
that just goes back to the places where
you just took it out from why not just
get no because the way the fat cells
work it's like they like they're taking
out the fatsa like it'll grow around it
Kazumi do is that what it looks like
probably so like I could try to find
pictures of like when I gain weight like
my abs just look strange so but I feel
like it gave me like a New Foundation
like surge what surgery does is it gives
you a new foundation and if your New
Foundation what you like the rest of
your journey is how well you actually
maintain that because a lot of girls you
know who will not tell you have bbls
their bbls just suck or like or just
like they just like lost like like lost
a fat in some way
um you you have to maintain it or else
it will look weird and how much do you
think you've spent in total on your body
I probably spent around 100K or so okay
yeah I mean well no problem how much did
each cost okay no I just can't [ __ ]
do math 8K okay lifo 360 and BBL 14k ABS
2K arm lipo 2K
face was expensive like 25k so probably
a little less than 100 I'm not counting
like post-op recovery and stuff like I
wore obviously when I got my BBL I wore
my Faja and I didn't sit for a long time
and stuff like that and I went and I
stayed in a recovery home really how's
that work you're not supposed to sit
well no last time she was here she had
this little bench thing remember I
didn't sit the whole podcast her butt
was hanging yeah it was like she was
sitting on her thighs right yeah oh my
God yeah and that's why I was like this
the whole time wow I was like way tall
like I was sitting on my giant cushion
oh my gosh okay yeah yeah geez but I
mean the ROI like I don't think I am
successful because I got surgery but I
will say it helped it helped it helped
not only because I feel like no I'm
number one more conventionally
attractive but I also just felt a lot
more confident like I would take more
opportunities I think it's the
confidence yeah I think you could have
done the same regardless but now that
you have the confidence you feel more
confident yeah through that especially
putting myself out there on social media
like getting on things like no jumper
and getting on like skits and stuff
where people are like hyper critical
about my appearance I felt like before I
would have just really lost a lot of
sleep over the things people would say
part of me like always in the back of my
mind maybe it's wrong maybe it's
completely wrong but part of me also
thinks like man I feel like porn can be
could be damaging to the young mind of
like a teenage boy or something like
that you know or growing up and and
getting that instant gratification all
of the time and then I feel like
inevitably in to some capacity you have
to
as a young person that continually
watches that regularly objectify women
in in some way or I feel it's hard to
avoid stuff like that what's the
difference of porn like if like a person
sees porn versus like if they see a
violent movie are they do you feel like
like
if people aren't able to understand that
this is entertainment is that the is
that the movie's fault is that the fault
of Transformers and Michael Bay or is it
the fault of the of the education you
receive in your household about how you
should feel about the things around you
I think the problem Jack is just having
an unrealistic expectation maybe that's
it that's just like expecting what you
see online to be a representation yeah
you know in the real world you
understand it's not necessarily
educational and it's also like obviously
anything in excess is bad you know if I
eat a bunch of french fries every day
and then I only eat french fries because
I don't know how to cook anything with
french fries it's gonna be pretty shitty
for me I I think when people say it porn
is harmful I think at the root of it we
need to start having better
conversations about sex and our
expectations on sex with people even
when they're younger you know about like
what porn is and what sexuality is and
what you're actually seeing and how it's
not necessarily a reflection of the
reality we live in it is a fantasy that
we're providing but on top of that with
only fans only fans is so much more
diverse in terms of like the content
you're able to see so it's not
necessarily always porn but even if it
were to be porn it's not necessarily
like the you know like a girl that looks
like me with like perfect proportions
[ __ ] guy with like a 10 inch dick it
could just be like normal looking people
doing normal things and when we start
normalizing it and start instead of
seeing it as like this taboo thing we
should all avoid we start realizing that
it's just an act that people do and not
necessarily something that is like evil
or should deserve or deserves
consequences for being enjoyed that
makes sense yeah yeah one thing one
final thought that I hear a lot right
not necessarily that I believe this but
I hear that like
porn can be damaging to the family unit
because people are getting married at a
lot older ages now and they're having
children at less rate Elon Musk tweeted
that he thinks that like the collapse of
the population is going to be one of the
biggest threats to humanity and I don't
know in the coming years or whatever
um because people can avoid going out
and trying to meet people in public and
their hormones that they have within
them right like for a dude like they're
testosterone like maybe it's depleted
when you
any weird thing that comes out that
guy's mouth but
um
I I don't think that's necessarily
porn's fault I think what's happening is
during covid people have really
had a hard time learning how to
communicate with each other
and kind of go outside and take chances
when they misunderstand one another I
feel like during covet everyone went
online and it's easy to say things and
it's easy to experience life on the
internet and that's not necessarily a
porn thing that's just the thing that
happened when everyone is forced to be
inside and now that we're all back
outside people have just kind of like
kind of absorb like these these same
type of social cues you learn on the
internet and now they're like bringing
it to people in real life and that's why
I feel like people are people seem
angrier to me you know and people seem a
lot harder to compromise with or like
kind of reach like a level ground and
that's not necessarily a porn thing
that's more so an internet thing you
know like I feel like we're just not
learning how to become more social and
learning how to communicate I don't
think there's a problem with people
getting married later I think as long as
people are getting married because they
want to get married and they're more
stable and they're able to create like a
loving present household whatever you
get married is totally fine
um and if porn was something that were
to become an issue in someone's
relationship that's not necessarily it's
not like a cigarette's fault you died
it's because like it's like your choices
for continually like chain smoking this
has been a long-standing trend though
yeah yes people you know getting married
later and all that not having kids but I
think it's a lot of the Internet it's
easier to have that interaction online
it's so much simpler than than going out
and like think of how much effort it
takes like get ready yeah go out you
have to be or you could just sit on the
computer do nothing and just share it
with your friends another thing that I
heard is that uh Millennials are getting
married later in part because they're
moving out of their parents home later
because they're choosing to stay home
and and save or it's too expensive to
move out so they stay at home I think
that's another big contributor and the
divorce rates when you get married after
25 drops substantially the more
education you have also drops uh yeah
because we all hear the statistic like
50 of divorce uh 50 of divorce has ended
marriage
marriages end in divorce but that takes
into account like third marriages or
like yeah I've been married twice your
chances of divorce are significantly
higher and I think actually uh more
recently it's about 65 stay married so
you're more likely to stay married but
then again you could also argue well
they haven't been together long enough
to maybe get divorced so like you have
to go through the entire life's you know
life you have to wait till they died you
have to wait till they die to get the
true statistics because one through
marriage for 20 years and then they you
know divorced is that you know at what
age does that happen yeah I think I
don't know people I think people are
getting also the thing of the internet
as I feel like people are able to when
people find their little Community
they're able to make more assumptions
about the monsters that they don't
understand and I feel like that just
create that creates more Division and I
feel like that like that destroys
communication you know I feel like for
example like someone can assume
something if I if you say only fans girl
people have a myriad of assumptions
about that based on what com what
community of the internet you're from
and from those assumptions people will
decide they don't want to give you the
time of day or they don't whereas in
real life when you would actually just
go outside to parties and meet people
people will tell you like hey I'm trans
or hey I'm different than you and people
will just have to learn how to navigate
the world with differences like that I
like how what I see like a deep value of
yours is just respect for people and I
think that's that that's really good I
think a lot of people lack respect for
people that you know have opposing
viewpoints that they have nowadays yeah
I just feel like it's important to learn
empathy first and foremost and I'm
coming from a place where I feel like I
I'm out I'm misunderstood often and one
part is because I put myself on the
internet and you know I dance and I talk
about gangbangs but at the same time I
don't feel like I need to
intellectualize intellectualize that
because I don't necessarily think doing
all that sexy stuff means I'm less
intelligent or like less deserving of
respect I feel like what speaks a lot
like most importantly is what I'm able
to contribute to the community and how I
make other people feel and if I make
people feel good what is the harm in
that you know if I make them feel good
in a healthy way where they understand
that the things that I create are
entertainment and not necessarily a
replacement for actual human connection
what are you doing now with all this
money that you're making where is it
going you know what I was telling
someone like most of my money was in the
s p and now I like every time I talk to
my finance people they're like look
there's a lot going on and I'm always
like uh I'm just gonna keep it there I
obviously had a little bit in crypto but
not enough but not a lot because I just
don't really understand the space enough
I
will get into real estate next year they
had issues with my tax return this year
so I just couldn't get into it but I
want to get a bunch of multi-families
and start either like Airbnb or doing
something with that I want to like
diversify my income into YouTube okay
then just get like other brand
opportunities that aren't necessarily
attached to me being like a sexual
person so I've been working on that you
know I did the billboard I did a YouTube
video on that so I'm going to see where
that takes me
um but mostly my money if it's not spent
on marketing and if it's not spent on
like putting it back into the s p then
it's me traveling and just living my
life I just came back from Berlin and I
just feel like people are the best books
and it was just such a different space
over there compared to here so I just
like want to continually understand
people
I like that
what are some of the the biggest
problems you see facing Society nowadays
um
questions this is so funny because I I
feel it's so funny because when I think
about our last interview I was like dick
sticks [ __ ] so we had like such a
difference I know this is a 180. I know
I like this person yeah I like I was
like let's forget what I said there
um you know what we could we could
charge uh money to see through and only
fans paywall to see that yeah I was
literally just like you actually yes I
was literally thinking that right as
soon as you said that the problem is
someone's gonna copy it yeah no and also
it's gonna get out like the things like
if they clip out something yeah and it
makes it to YouTube so I already
combated that idea yeah okay you're good
at dmca and then just keep fighting it
but it'll come out regardless yeah it's
gonna come out yeah
um
I think the biggest problem this is
these are such like giant questions I
think the biggest problem
um nowadays
I want to put Andrew Tate for a
hydraulic press bro I think he is my
Hitler I think he is like one of the
worst things to come about in this world
why because I think when you it's not
that his views are new it's the fact
that he is able to influence so many
impressionable people who are already
who are looking for people just like
them to find a community and then he
he gets you with this thing where it
starts off of being with like with a
self-fulfillment which is something we
should all do but then he makes it
something hateful and it just doesn't
it's not going to create a better world
for us it's it's it creates a more
hateful divisive world when we put
people in boxes and we have expectations
for each other
that are and we pretend that this
reality is an objective reality we all
have to follow the same rules in when
that's not the case like the world is so
much bigger than the small Niche
community that you're talking to but
what you're doing is you're creating a
more violent world and when you
desensitize people with jokes and just
and with with jokes like that or or just
like
you know they and these people already
don't know how to talk about to
articulate how they feel and their
differences and they already feel alone
and angry it's just going to you all you
do is create violence you you create a
more violent world for people that you
don't like because I've already started
seeing like smaller people in the same
van as Andrew Tain started branching out
and start spewing their own hateful
things about black people about trans
people about this about that and what
you're doing is you're making it okay to
be hateful and I feel like
I'll get crucified for this but I didn't
have a I don't have a huge problem with
like woke culture I think if we're as
long as we are working towards just
making this a more comfortable place for
all of us to navigate in
let's [ __ ] do it some it's not cancel
culture it's sometimes people say
something insane and they should there
should be consequences for that you know
there should be opportunities that are
lost because you should not be able to
influence people that way and I feel
like as long as we keep enabling that
type of behavior and again I'll get
crucified for this because I did an
e-date with Andrew Tate and I got the
clout off that and I also obviously make
money you know what was it what was the
e-date so I didn't eat it with Aiden
Ross I didn't know who Andrew Tade was I
just was trying to win
um but I just was trying to win so I was
saying things like yes you can
impregnate me and we can create like a
family and I think that was one of the
clips that I saw I'm sorry you saw that
I didn't know who he was afterwards all
my friends were like
dude what the [ __ ] that was the first
time I ever heard of him I'm not really
in that Circle of the world but then he
became like this huge deal and even now
just talking about him I hated because I
can recognize the game what he's doing
is causing discussion which is what I do
all the time but I just feel like it's
like why is the discussion continually
about rationalizing my Humanity you know
it's like I don't want to play Devil's
Advocate when you're playing with my
life and I feel like people don't think
that way or they think he's playing with
your life in what way he's playing with
the lives of like women you know and I
and I feel like what do you do like what
he does is he becomes this figurehead
for guys who identify with Dad but those
guys are never going to become Andrew
Tate you know but
with Windows guys some of them are going
to become big in their own sense and
they're going to copy the same
techniques like what I did and they're
just going to create a more hateful
world you know when you when you start
saying that women don't have thoughts or
women should have their body counts on
their heads and you're talking
to you're speaking to the choir of
people who already agree with you
because they already don't want to try
to understand women then yeah it does
create violence because when those
people enter relationships like those
people just won't be happy you're gonna
say or or you you're implying that those
guys are going to say oh you've been
with too many people and we're gonna cut
this you're they're worth is tied to
tied to that is what you're saying what
they're doing is I feel like we are
radicalizing young men into because the
algorithm once you interact with a
subject with some subject matter you
will be inundated with that propaganda
yes memes are propaganda that's
something I've learned myself like the
more you
like like like these children are being
radicalized and it's going to create a
worse world like it's increasingly
becoming more difficult to call out
people when they say something insane
right like
like Kanye West saying something about
George Floyd overdosing on fentanyl or
saying something about Jews that should
not be a thing you should be able you
should be comfortable saying so why is
that even a controversial take you know
like I'm gonna say that right now it's
gonna get clipped people are gonna fight
in the comments but why are we even at
this point in society where people even
want to rationalize that we need better
Heroes but what I'm trying to say is
like one of the most I said Andrew Tate
but what I mean to say is that
like
we are like the big one of the biggest
problems in the world right now is the
fact that we are radicalizing people
into really extreme positions like into
really extreme ideology ideologies
that's just one example I think that's
social media in general yeah you have to
be an extreme one side or the other the
middle gets no attention so you have to
be like yeah you have to take extreme
views because that's what gets the
engagement which gets pushed and that's
kind of the issue and it's kind of a
thing that's a catch-22 again I'm a
hypocrite you know because I obviously
lean into being extreme and talking
about extreme stuff because what gets
views you know like sometimes if I just
talk about my normal life then it
doesn't get views and it feels like a
waste of time but
those choices are are very brave you
know because sometimes you don't want to
say those things because I don't want to
say this and then I'll lose my social
media the difficult part is I feel like
there's not a lot of self-help out there
for young men there's really not that's
genuine that's just not built on hate
yeah yeah but I think there's a lot of a
lot of young guys out there who are just
if they're spending a lot of time online
they don't get that practice socializing
in it and it takes you like going out
all the time and meeting friends and
putting yourself out there and it's
really really really difficult uh and
there's not that sort of guide out there
really to to show people I think in a
way that's that's maybe productive or or
really is more like a step-by-step
tutorial of like hey you gotta go and
introduce yourself to five people today
and shake hands and follow up with 20
people uh hang out with someone tonight
it's like all that sort of stuff you
have to kind of learn on your own yeah
that's why I liked Europe when I like
went like last week because I was just
it was just a very much more in-person
Society and because it was a more
in-person Society I found it more of a I
wasn't specifically in Berlin I founded
much more of a tolerant Society because
I felt like you just meet people and
then you realize that they're different
and then if you care about someone and
they say something that isn't that is
hurtful you say hey I I don't think you
should say that and I'm saying that
because I care about you not because I
have a moral compass and I'm white
knighting or I'm trying a virtue signal
because it makes me feel good I'm saying
because I want to keep you in my life
and you make me uncomfortable when you
say [ __ ] like that and I feel like
that's a sentence that so many people
just can't say
I feel like it's terribly difficult for
them to say that and if I am wrong about
something I'm comfortable saying like
Okay I should not have
said that you know there's consequences
of that I've of things I've said on no
jumper that I will live with you know
but I understand the consequences of my
actions when I say those things and how
it impacts people yeah I think it's just
a lot at the end of the day of building
someone's self-esteem and finding their
place and passion in the world and I
think it's going through that
self-discovery it's it's probably from
the age of like 15 to I would say 30 for
a lot of people it's like those ages I
think are so just like formative yeah
you have to want to change yourself and
try to want to improve and I think a lot
of people either want a shortcut or they
just have no interest and I think what
happens is you're in a community
and number one it's hard to tell your
friends like say hey shit's not funny
because you don't want to be you don't
want people to make fun of you but you
don't want to be out ousted from this
community you know when you enter like
you know a certain part of the internet
whether it's on Reddit or Twitter and
you say something that people disagree
with you know sometimes you have to
leave that community and a lot of people
for a lot of people who aren't socially
adjusted that's like the worst thing
that could ever happen to them and so
they will just kind of like laugh along
or cut or start internalizing the
propaganda or seeing and say yeah women
don't have thoughts you know and that's
at first it starts with a joke and then
they start kind of being like no like I
mean everyone kind of agrees with me
right and then sometimes they say
something and someone says you shouldn't
say that and they say [ __ ] you [ __ ]
like I'm able to say it because I'm you
know I'm this person and I have a blue
check and and I feel like it's just a
catch-22 of like just a very toxic
ideology that's one of the things that's
wrong in this world right now
is there a female version of this
I I'm sure there is I don't necessarily
subscribe to that I would say what
people argue is what you say earlier is
that they've believed that is that out
from outside looking in people will say
that porn is can be a toxic thing but
again I believe that's just your own
relationship with sex because I feel
like a lot of people watch porn and they
have healthy relationships with people
outside in the world you know I don't
think that's a necessary deterrent for
having communication I think if you're
terminally online and you don't
communicate with people outside of
people just like you then you will have
problems no matter what
um
I I feel like they're I'm sure there are
like like like toxic female things I
feel like they're I feel like with women
a lot of the toxic things that that are
part of like certain communities
exist in retaliation to the way they
feel about men probably you know you
know what that reminds me uh on Reddit
there's uh the thing is what was it the
red pill the opposite of that that I
heard on Reddit and I read some of this
it's wild it's called female dating
strategies oh wait I've seen that and
some of that stuff is so funny oh my God
we should pull up we should just pull up
like one of the top threads sure and see
what they say okay some other stuff is
so funny okay actually I lied I
definitely have some female friends who
I feel like again
have like I think the problem is just
having like weird expectations about the
other sex for whatever reason like
feeling like you owe me money or or like
whatever because I have [ __ ] and
whatever and then weaponizing sex to
kind of make sure that you do my life I
don't know
but I just feel like just grow out of it
like money like one thing that's being
propagandized if that's a word on the
other side to uh maybe not a similar
degree but just in general is like the
hate all men type thing which I've heard
a lot and in fact uh I actually went on
a tender date with someone who hated it
all men subscribed to the hate all men
ideology oh which didn't really make
sense to me personally because she was
on a date with me yeah it didn't
necessarily make me feel very secure nor
confident in the was she like joking or
was she no I I think when women say that
I like to think what they mean is they
don't like
the systemic things that patriarchy has
created over the history of time that
have made living and navigating this
world as a woman difficult
or maybe she means the actual male race
I don't know I think that they're
probably combining the two yeah yeah
like like because of this you should
think this you know yeah yeah I think
it's
I don't see the thing is in terms of
like
men in cells and and Femme cells I I
guess I kind of see like where this pain
comes from but it's just like a Mis it's
so misguided well what really is going
to help us is focusing on first of all
our individualized relationships with
each other and not like basing like the
choices we make based off memes and [ __ ]
we see on the internet and actually just
getting to know someone whatever the
hell their astrology sign or whatever
the hell their credit score is
um
yeah I think it's just the extremism on
both sides yeah it's really hard to
think for yourself because it's a lot
easier just to be told what to think
yeah especially from people that are put
in positions of power right where if
they have that blue check you're like oh
I should believe them or some sports
celebrity says something and you're like
I should believe them because they're
successful and they're given Niche yeah
I was telling someone I feel like it's
because as a I'm not religious but I
feel like because people just generally
aren't more like like people defend
Kanye West like he's like Jesus or
something like it's insane to me I feel
like because people aren't necessarily
like religion work for a long time and I
guess it still does work because there
was again the sense of community where
people felt like they had like a common
objective which was to go to heaven or
whatever and now it's like I I just feel
personally I feel personally
connected to Tory Lanez no matter what
he says or does you know and I feel like
because of this like intense celebrity
culture where we're seeing all this news
and these people can pay each other off
to like post like whatever propaganda
they want like a lot of impressional
people are able to just choose sides and
like really stand our ground and loyalty
with these on about these people that
don't even know
yeah I couldn't find anything on them
that was interesting yeah it would take
me too what is the female dating
strategy I think it's it's the women's
version I could be totally off here the
women's version of The Red Pill where I
think it's
I I hate making making up an explanation
here but that's probably all I'll leave
it at yeah without doing my research
yeah I was like you were like I think
it's bad no I remember reading something
back then of like yeah you want to do
this and you're don't tell him this and
you better not call him back at this
time it's like like the the pickup
version for women oh I see I think I
always tell people like nowadays
when you are an adult woman and I'm like
I'm 25. and it's like I I talk to people
the type of person I like is someone who
number one has a healed perspective on
women and isn't ashamed about sex and
believe and that doesn't believe sex
should have con enjoying sex should have
consequences which I feel like a lot of
people feel like like you like sex
that's really bad like you mean it
should only be with someone like you
really really like movies like pick up
artists both for men men and women
I feel I mean they probably existed
before the internet when people struggle
to like find a date and stuff but it's
like as an adult woman I decide if I
wanna get to know a guy like just
talking to him and any type of strategy
like uh it's just coercion after a point
because either I decided I wanted to
spend time with you or I didn't if you
keep kind of badgering me with like
whatever you think is like a clever line
or whatever I mean I'll I just most
times it just doesn't work because I
already decided I'm not attracted to you
in some sensor form the best thing you
can do is just focus on making sure
you're your best self yeah I agree with
that I think a lot of it is learning how
to Showcase who you are as a person and
then you attract what you are yeah but I
think most guys out there have no idea
how to do that in terms of like
effectively communicating who they are
what they stand for uh and building up
that confidence and that's why I think I
don't think it's a line or anything I I
totally disagree with the idea of like
oh you gotta think of a super clever
response and wait three hours to respond
because it's just like just be who you
are and is that working for you jack
fantastic it's great okay okay maybe not
sometimes but I'm not really putting
myself out there okay Jack's
conversation is going great though in
the beginning though thanks we've gotten
more confident and I think confidence is
a huge part of being able to be
attractive you know what I mean yeah I
feel like you just attract what you are
like when I was in a very insecure girl
coming out of my dad's house I attracted
people who were just as insecure and
sick and twisted you know and now that I
just know myself that people I talk to
are just as confident and just and just
as attractive and as long as you are
presenting your best best self you're
going to attract people who are
attracted to that which is what they are
and there's no game to play really can
you say one thing that you like or a
good thing about Andrew Tate
um
I I like his I respect his strategy his
strategy with the hustle thing was cool
which is why I did it with my Sims or
slash fans you know what I mean like I
anyone who can get to any type of
who can get such a huge audience is not
an idiot you know like you and every
like you I'm not an idiot you know like
no matter what people if you I don't
have to agree with anything he says to
not recognize that whatever he is he is
a very smart guy and he knows how to do
a lot of things which a lot of people
don't do which is do which is how to
influence and that's what he's doing
he's learning how to influence people
like even right now unwarranted I'm
talking about him you know because I
have a strong opinion about that and if
people talk about me then that means
that I have influence
um but most of all I just respected his
um like his like affiliate link strategy
thing I found that a very smart thing
and what do you think are some pillars
of a successful relationship what does a
relationship need and like like a
romantic relationship
um shared values shared values I feel
like ultimately if I believe something
about and I'm not just saying like you
like pineapple pizza I don't like
pineapple pizza but I'm saying certain
things like okay like if I wanted to get
an abortion are we able to do that or is
that something you just couldn't do or
like what are your thoughts financially
about like if I need to move across this
country are we going to move
um shared values is the biggest thing
and shared interest too you know I want
to be able to talk to someone who like
just knows likes the same things I do or
at least is open to it you know I I
think another thing too is just like you
just gotta wanna you you have to like me
and I think a lot of the times the
chemistry I think a lot of times people
forget that crucial thing in
relationships is
I feel like sometimes people want to
establish a power Dynamic you know like
they're like maybe because that's how
they were when they were kids and their
parents had a power Dynamic but I don't
want to control you and I don't want you
to control me ultimately we are together
because you like me and I like you and I
want to spend time with you and I want
to grow with you in some capacity maybe
not forever but I like you and and that
goes for even like friends you know I
don't establish certain rigid
expectations on my best friend why would
I do it with my boyfriend I'm in an open
relationship but even if I was in a
monogamous relationship is my person is
my person able to navigate the world
comfortable knowing that I won't get mad
over everything like is he happy to be
with me because I'm happy to be with him
I I don't
all all relationships you know you get
you give each other stuff you know not
necessarily because it's based on
transactional things but
like
I want to feel happy when I'm with you
you know and I feel you just have to
like someone you don't have to come into
a relationship thinking like I need you
to do this and I you know you can't go
outside with your friends at 10 pm on a
friend's birthday because that's what
let's do you know like I want to know
that I'm able to be my own person
yeah I would actually agree with that I
think the three that I always end up
saying are like shared values shared
interests and just general chemistry
which is General chemistry and it's just
like learning how to be independent I
want to want you I don't want to need
you I don't want my lifestyle to be bit
which is why I always preach to women
you need to be financially independent
it's not cute it's not cute to depend on
a guy to say to like to to like because
you don't want to demean yourself
because this guy pays rent you know like
I want to be able to be in a
relationship because I want to and if
we're not happy then I can just leave I
don't have to consider like oh my God I
like my car is under your name like
you'll take my car if you don't like me
anymore I think trust is another big one
trust yeah yeah are you signing a prenup
yeah yeah as you should you know we've
talked so openly about this yeah yeah
you believe in prenups yeah I'll sign a
prenup but I again don't go into my
relationships thinking about what they
can do for me you know I can't I came
into it because I just liked the person
and
I mean whatever makes them feel
comfortable is just what I'm going to do
within reason no you said you're only
fans with three dollars a month my only
fans is three dollars a month I'm not
shouting it out but you guys I know
where to find it okay so how do you
break up your only fans like
percentage-wise like tips subscription
how does it total what was it like three
four hundred thousand dollars a month or
something I probably make around 300 000
a month now last month was kind of low
at 274. but the month before that I did
334 which is cool and I also have a
fansy which generates about 40 to 50K a
month that's just my only fans backup
three dollars is a low acquisition cost
for you to be able to see hundreds and
thousands of pictures and videos now if
you want a more personalized connection
such as like a scene with me and Johnny
Sins or like a sex thing that would be
an additional cost I keep everything
reasonable you know because again I'm
here for a sustainability you know I'm
here for a long time not I'm Here for a
Good Time analog
how would you allocate the little pieces
of the pieces messages is a big one
because obviously like people buy videos
into messages or like well sext like if
you want me to on the spot get naked in
this like Denny's bathroom I guess I'll
do it for thirty dollars you know right
now I'm okay sure
um if I
I would say a big thing too is
subscriptions like the dose three
dollars [ __ ] add up because I would
say about a thousand or so people join
every day just to see what's going on
you know because three dollars is a low
acquisition cost to be like okay I could
see what's I like it I feel or and a lot
of my friends also just support what I
do they see the billboard and they're
like that's funny you know and it'll
they'll sort support that way so I feel
like those things are kind of like the
main stuff that like make me a lot of
money
love it cool all right thank you so much
thank you so much appreciate it back on
Kazumi we really appreciate it was way
better than the first one fantastic yeah
it's a great episode so thank you guys
so much I really appreciate it make sure
to subscribe we'll link to your info
check me out on Instagram her Instagram
will be linked Down Below in the
description
stock enjoy see you guys I want a free
stock public.com